BTS fans j-hope is serving us some jay
Biebs meanwhile chadwick boseman is
surprising emotional Black Panther fans
and Tiffany Haddish is still fangirling
over meeting Oprah what a time to be
alive folks I know things seem bleak but
there's hope
j-hope fans of the k pop sensation group
BTS welcome to a treat this morning
j-hope finally dropped his mixtape and a
video for daydream but I'm sorry army
we're gonna hold onto that til tomorrow
for a new music Friday but in the
meantime j-hope is showing off more than
his impressive rap skills he dropped a
short rendition of mega hit despot Seto
again this time after Billboard magazine
asked BTS where is their favorite place
to tour dare I say he sounds better than
Justin Bieber I'm just saying let's get
BTS on a reggaeton track alright
meanwhile Black Panthers start chadwick
boseman gave fans the thrill of their
lives after he surprised them with the
help of Jimmy Fallon and the reactions
ranged from emotional well for me as the
mother of a young son my son's childhood
has been defined by Barack Obama and now
Black Panther so thank you hey that's
way too much praise
two down right comedy I do have a life
but I saw it four times I saw it once
with a girlfriend
also I want to thank you for having your
suit on for most of the movie because
when the chest was out she was getting a
little excited and I felt insecure so
thank you for that um and it means a lot
to see a movie that's not like a black
movie but it's just a great American
superhero movie with uh you know people
that look like me so thank you brolic
and stuff it would have been weird
clearly Black Panther has made a huge
impact on folks out there something that
is not lost on Chadwicks co-star and in
my opinion the fiercest of the bunch
mr. Nager era what about all the little
girls around the country little boys -
who look at you now and say you are the
fiercest warrior in all of Wakanda you
know like they look at you as this
fierce warrior this superhero in any way
shape or form this derivative
representation can actually impact a
young child in a way that makes them
feel more validated or more empowered or
more connected to their own potential or
more aware of their own greatness I mean
that's everything
what else could you possibly want more
than that preach all right that was et's
Kevin Frazier with deny at alfre woodard
ninth annual Oscars sister soiree on
Wednesday it's there that keV also
caught up with Tiffany Haddish who is
clearly still shook after her surprise
meeting with Oprah
people still can't talk stop talking
about you and Oprah what did it really
freak you out like that did it really
cure it touch my entire soul I want look
okay I want to hear the rep and ask her
what should I wear to the Oscars like I
want her to give me advice about
everything in life Oprah should I wear
this era train African dress to the
Oscars
on a red carpet to represent my daddy
because my daddy from Eritrea he passed
away and I want to pay respect I want to
show the world - thank you
they should all call me I'm telling you
she's gonna call you I guarantee oh well
we'll have to wait until Sunday to see
what Oprah helps Tiffany wear to the
Academy Awards and of course Jimmy
Kimmel is jumping back on the horse as
the host again following last year's
epic Best Picture mix-up I got to tell
you as a kid I've always loved watching
the Oscars and then when that happened
it gave me life folks back with some
damn good TV but is it giving a host
Jimmy PTSD or et's Kevin Frazier once
again found out you know I dream about
it every night there's a mistake
moonlight you guys won Best Picture
is there any PTSD no no not no in fact
it went great except for the thing at
the end with you know turned out to be a
something that was interesting to people
you know and I guess the the worst thing
the Oscars can be is boring I think
right what will be different from last
year
it seems like every year there are
serious things happening this year it
seems like there are nine of them all
happening at once so that's something
that I think has to be handled has to be
balanced but I also know that they have
to memorize every single winner for
every category yeah for the first time
ever Oh
before they yeah well that's interesting
I think that in Crete I just tell you
something evil yeah I don't know
anything what makes you think I know
more than you I thought you knew
everything that's not my show I'm just
posting it and I I just hoping to be on
be funny keep the show moving and have
some stuff that maybe people will talk
about the next day well if the Oscars is
your kind of thing and you got a horse
in the race
then make sure you join me tomorrow at
10:30 a.m. Pacific on et's Facebook
Twitter or YouTube channel for a live
preview of Hollywood's biggest night and
if you've ever wondered how much booze
these stars drink there or how much is
the gift bag I got that info too so come
check us out and I'll see you then good
bye